I'm not going to spend the entire show
on the Fox News text message Revelations
but there is one more set of Revelations
that I want to talk about with you
some of these newly revealed texts
expose that Fox News propaganda's Maria
Bartiromo and former Trump
um advisor Stephen Bannon
are True Believers okay with Tucker
Carlson we learned he was pretending he
hates Trump doesn't like him at all
thinks he's a hates him
passionately looked forward to when he
could stop talking about Trump Maria
Bartiromo and Steve Bannon seem to be
actual True Believers this is completely
insane
Steve Bannon and Maria Bartiromo reports
Media Matters plotted to discredit Biden
and get barter Romo elected to the
Senate Bannon texted 71 million voters
will never accept Biden this process is
to destroy his presidency before it
starts if it even starts
um
this is so insane okay let's look at a
couple of the text messages Maria text
Steve Bannon oh my God I'm so depressed
I can't take this can you join me
Thursday sorry about the delay
Bannon writes back yes we've got this
Maria Bartiromo says I am watching the
world move forward and it's so upsetting
Steve Maria is upset that the world is
moving forward with Joe Biden as the
president why well because Joe Biden won
Maria adds I want to see massive fraud
exposed will he be able to turn this
around I told my team we are not allowed
to say president-elect at all not in
scripts or in banners on air until this
moves through the courts
um Bannon then responded as Media
Matters writes uh 71 million voters will
never accept Biden this process is to
destroy his presidency before it starts
if it even starts and Bartiromo replied
but I'm scared and sad
and Bannon says you are our fighter
enough with the sad we need you
we need we want you to run against
Schumer this is your moment Bannon then
texted barter Roma what he called the
plan listen to this number one we either
close on Trump's Victory or delegitimize
Biden two win both seats in Georgia that
didn't happen three win back the house
in 2022 okay that did happen four elect
you to the Senate 5. if we don't close
on Trump Victory now have Trump declare
for 2024 the day after taking back the
house and your win in November of 2022.
now of course Maria Bartiromo did not
end up running for Senate
Trump did end up announcing that he was
running but instead of right after the
2022 midterms it was right before the
2022 midterms they seem to be true
believers now I want to add one caveat
here
Steve Bannon may be pretending for the
benefit of Maria Bartiromo okay Steve
Bannon is Devious and smart enough that
even these text messages to me leave
open the possibility that Bannon doesn't
believe any of this crap but he
recognizes that Maria Bartiromo does and
so he's playing it up to her
I don't know but there are definitely
some True Believers out there my
question to you what's worse the true
believers who are completely
disconnected from reality like Maria
Bartiromo or
the people that are just lying like
Tucker Carlson who knows Trump didn't
win
who doesn't like Trump who hates Trump
passionately but they go on air and they
pretend reality is different which is
worse let me know what you think leave
it in a comment and you can find all of
these clips and text messages on our
Instagram by searching Instagram for
David packman show